[Music]  uh  first learned about this seven years ago  on a mission in brazil  to capture a wanted fugitive  when we got there it tore through our  unit in seconds  the target has superhuman abilities  [Applause]  [Music]  it had the same marking you do cole  it's a birthmark what do you mean he was  born with it  it's not a birthmark cole means you've  been chosen  throughout history different cultures  all over the world  reference a great tournament  of champions that dragon marking  i think it's an invitation to fight for  something known  as mortal kombat  these are your champions i'm sonya  that's kano i'm luke  [Applause]  no matter how many of my people you put  in the ground  we will not fail kill them  i am sub-zero  get over here  you [ __ ] beauty  you